they hand you this f of X and they say
hey it is a probability density function
so we're not asking like oh is it or
isn't it they're telling us it is and
that's helpful because we can make
certain assumptions about it if that's
the case right namely this is that
second condition that we know all
probability density functions must obey
I've substituted instead of negative
infinity and infinity here I put in a
and B because practically I'm you will
usually get an A and a B it's defined in
this domain okay so what I'm gonna do is
because I know it's a probability
density function I'm going to make this
statement for this particular function
okay so I'm gonna say my integral is not
just from A to B my boundaries are zero
six fantastic now here comes the
function part which has to include even
though it's slightly awkward it has to
include this unknown right K now I did
get asked the question it was a good
question like hey this is multiple
choice right can I just like try those
values yeah just put it in and then see
what happens the short answer is
absolutely you can but you may be taking
either a really lucky way it's like my
first answer worked or really unlucky
way which is that I had to get all the
way to entity and then like I had to
trial I had to waste all this time
trying a B and C okay not to mention of
course we want to be able to handle a
question like this even when we don't
get given options right we want to go
just work it out which we can so I'm
gonna take this I'm gonna integrate with
respect to X and the thing is I know
what the answer this question is because
it's a probability density function all
my probabilities ought to add to one
okay now at this point I'm like okay
calculus hat back on okay I'm going to
integrate this guy and my primitive
function will be X careful yeah it's
gonna be x squared over 90 and you can
just mentally check like if I
differentiate that will I come back yes
I will okay
but then that K I'm not differentiating
remember I'm integrating the K becomes K
X very good so this is going to be
something that gets evaluated when I put
in my batteries which are naught and six
okay
and I'll leave it weird we usually know
all the stuff over here and then we get
an answer out but we're doing this in
Reverse we actually know what the answer
is and we know the end at the beginning
and now we have to see what this K is
right now that's alright because these
zero in six are going to replace all my
X's so all the X's will go be replaced
by numbers the only unknowns will be K
all right so let's just go ahead make
sure we know what our working will look
like here's my upper boundary six
squared on 90 + 6 K are you okay with my
substitution it looks right okay and
then I'm subtracting my lower boundary
and I notice as happens frequently there
are X terms in both of these spots right
so when the zero goes in here and then
when the zero goes in here it all just
disappears right so I'm just subtracting
zero is that okay
and that's nice that's equal to 1 and
this point all I need to do is simplify
this stuff make hey the subject said all
right 6 squared on 90 36 on 90 what's 36
on 96 art if it's Tiffy's what is the
common 18 of course okay so I've got 2/5
plus 6 okay equals one song I subtract
gives me 3/5 and that means our final
line okay will equal three over 30 which
is 1 over 10 is that one of our answers
that's a relief isn't it okay so option
C that's how we did it okay
so like I said they're like ah this
calculus stuff I know how to do it's
just that which we take this property of
a probability density function and we
use that to be able to work out these
unknowns on the left hand side which is
a slightly different now I think you
guys can have a go at 8 in your own time
you can see again they hand you a
probability density function they're
asking you to find some probabilities
let's just make sure you're heading on
the right track I'll do the first line
and then I'll let you guys take it from
there before I am I do want to quickly
talk you through these so a question 8
what's the probability density function
that they give us f of x equals what
to Exxon 25 within what domain 0 to 5
thank you very much and then I'm
assuming it says zero otherwise yeah and
you can see this is what we were talking
about yesterday right this happens all
the time because you're like this
function looks like my daughter but only
in this little window so just take it in
that window and ignore it for the rest
of it okay now they want us then to work
out a series of probabilities so for
this first one our boundaries are from
one and a half to two and a half like so
so I can get an integral I can interpret
an integral out of this probability that
they're asking for right I'm gonna have
my definite integral where do I got my
boundaries from I think because there's
a few different places I could take it
from it it's just it's just from here
right it's from this particular question
it's not from here because I already
know that would give me everything so
that would be one I don't need to know
that I want this specific little section
of the probabilities then I put in my
function 2x on 25 and then off I go I
reckon you guys could do that half in
your sleep okay now I just quickly want
you to have a look and you pick up that
piece of paper because you'll be able to
do all this question I reckon on your
own I think you'll be fine with question
2 on this piece of paper as well I just
want you to have a look at question 3 so
you can signal to me that you're ready
by putting a pen down and then picking
this up so you can have a look at it
closely so finish whatever line you're
working you're on and then just show me
you've got that piece of paper in your
eyes thanks Eddie that's very helpful
okay all right have a look at it with me
it says let f of X equal they give you a
function it's defined on the closed
interval 0 comma 4 so there's our
boundaries okay
now Part A says show that and they give
you an integral it equals 1 why are they
asking this well why would they care
about some integral equaling 1 think
about what I've been doing
they're trying to they're trying to meet
the conditions they're trying to meet
the conditions of probability density
functions right so they're checking this
one okay but then they say papi sure
nevertheless but f of X is not a valid
probability density function and they
even give you a hint now let's think
about this right
we've already satisfied if Part A is
right we've satisfied one condition
what's the other one again can't be less
than zero it's always got to be zero or
above so that tells you even though you
don't know what this graph looks like it
tells you what you're expecting to find
there's probably gonna be some negatives
in there and I need to show that okay so
we're gonna leave the rest of this
lesson for you guys to get your head
wrapped around this this world in which
there's a lot of familiar stuff but the
language in which they asked it in the
notation is different okay
question two which is the the first
question on there
I didn't address this because I wanted
you to get to it and think what does
that mean the question is quite long
before they get to the ABCDEF the second
part of the question says determine
whether or not each function is a
probability density function we've
covered how to do that you're looking
for those two conditions and then
there's this little kicker there it says
if it is a probability density function
because some of them aren't if it is one
find its mode and then they give you
this a little hit they say look for
global Maxima and you're like I don't
know what either of those things means
so pause for a minute and remember one
of the examples that I gave you
yesterday was to imagine a probability
density function that represented the
heights of our cost you remember that so
I I don't know I drew something like
like that okay now if this really is a
probability density function then I can
use it to find the mode so long as I
remember what mode is inner in a group
of scores we've got mode mean and median
right means the average median is the
middle score what's mode representing
the most frequently occurring the most
common one right now if this is a
probability density function I should be
able to look at this and say ah
the most common height in the classroom
must be the one that is most probable if
I picked one of you at random right the
most probable thing will be the mode or
vice-versa
the mode
we'll be the most probable theme okay so
what this means is the way you can find
a mode on a probability density function
is to go back to last topic and say
where is our maximum value and that's
why they say look for global Maxima now
that way global think think think the
word global is important because on the
basis of your function you might not
find the global Maxima at a turning
point right this is a turning point but
you can pretty easily think of a
function where the global maximum does
not occur ad at any point let me give
you a couple right here's one here's a
probability density function right I
have a turning point it's down here it's
a minimum I'm looking for the most
common thing not the least common thing
so therefore I'm gonna find it at and
end point that make sense well I mean in
this I can have what we call bimodal
data does that do you remember that it's
a if I have if half of us are this
height and the other half of that height
you have both the modes that make sense
yeah okay or just as easily just as
easily imagine if I had a function that
looks like this this stationary point
right there it's a maximum stationary
point it's fresh should say a maximum
turning point but it's not the global
maximum because you still have this end
point over here because of however your
domain is defined that actually ends up
being the real maximum okay so you have
to search for those and that's why go
back to your notes on optimization if
this is like not ringing bells because
that's part of why we learned this okay